I'm sure you want to have a party for Stella don't you think maybe we should just be us. No, I wish we had a party
For your dad when he.. When we put him to sleep
Baby meet the gang. This is everyone. I love and Ron
Actually me and Jack met last year at a party. She never called me back. What?
Jack saw this girl that he was in love with on the train today. She never called him back either.
I'm sure she had her reasons
Take your shoes off over there the floors are like imported from the ancient Roman ruins
Okay, that's for the invited guests Oliver. You can't have any
Do you want it back?
Woah, now I feel better
Hey becoming a Stella celebration Sunday something wrong with that, right? Yeah. Let's celebrate our dog dying.
Look, Jack its a birds nest
Hey, you never see him at its worst tell your mother
I just asked whether you're the type of woman that man wanted to bang a man wanted to marry
So, where did you say you kidding me, right?
Come on I thought it was just gonna be you me and Stella. What, can't we be friends?
You can't go out on a school night later. Mom young man old man. You spoiled the boys
You're not learning how to be men
She makes these other girls look like flying monkeys in the Wizard of Oz I'm just really really happy something bad happened to your mom
Don't go near that girl again no matter how much you like her. Where'd you go to sleep? We love you
Smella and M doesn't even look like a T.  It's okay. Stella can't read mom.
I don't know what i'm doing, I dont know what to do.
I liked you so much. I like you so much.
I'm always worried about girls liking you better, but she had the choice and she chose me. Could be awkward
Well, you guys have this so precious and beautiful
That's the end of the story. Yeah. Thats the most depressing story I've ever heard in my life